各位太扯了
真的是太扯了
這個
還有這個
全部都是用
Gemini Nano Banana Pro 一鍵生成的
嗨各位又是我 AJ
Nano Banana 誕生以來才短短不到兩個月的時間
上個禮拜直接天元突破大更新
今天這集影片
我們會先從 Nano Banana 的基本操作
到後面我們會直接跟你分享
大量的狂到炸裂的應用方法
還有 Pro讓你直接複製去用
感謝本集的冠名夥伴
傳譯寶APP
主打會議AI摘要
語音轉文字
讓你不用在會後瘋狂補筆記
好不好用
我們在這一集直接示範給你看
有冠名夥伴為頻道撐腰
我們才能帶來這麼多精彩的內容
好
那我們來快速的帶領大家
進入Nano Banana Pro的這個模型吧
第一個你可以使用
gemini.google.com
然後去點啟用圖像
然後這邊記得選一個叫做
3 Pro 的思考型模型
看到那個香蕉
然後看到思考型模型
你就會用到最新的AI Pro的圖片生成
第二個你可以去 AI Studio這個網站
如果你用 Gemini 的官方網站
其實你可以免費的去生成這些圖片
但是會有一些額度上的限制
然後它會有浮水印
那如果你用 AI Studio 這個網站去生成
那你需要付費綁信用卡
然後它是每張每張圖片會跟你算錢
那第三個就如果你本身是
Google Workspace 的用戶
他們之後會把它整合到
Google的簡報
Google Slide裡面
所以如果你在Google Slide裡面
看到可以用這個圖片生成
模型一旦更新
馬上就可以用到這個 Pro 的模型
另外一個重點就是
大家在用這個圖片的時候
你可能會想說
這東西可不可以商業使用
目前Google官方並沒有明確說明
可以或不可以
整個Nano Banana現在它能夠支援的解析度
有分成 1K 2K 跟 4K
直接用 Pro 的方式要求它去調整比例
除了 1比 1 之外
它還可以做成比如說 9比 16
這個是直式手機
或者是16比9 橫式簡報
再來 3比4或4比3
那3比4這種是手機的直式拍照
4比3是那種比較舊式的投影機的比例
再來就是 3比2跟2比3還有5比4
這個是傳統底片的比例
那另外你還可以出一種叫4比5
那4比5根據我查到的資料
是IG的人像照片的最佳比例
最後一個是21比9
這個是那種寬螢幕的
好那我們就來上實作吧
第一個幫我設計一個
居家自我伸展步驟圖
日式流行雜誌風
說明文字都要台灣繁體中文
那你就可以看到
帶一些日文字的設計
然後中文字看起來都非常的精準
那同樣的
比如說我們要製作一張海報
扁平設計的人物還有各種形狀
主題是12月25號
在PenBar舉辦的啤酒大賽
那你就會獲得像這樣的一張海報
那當然如果你對它這個風格
你就會不滿意
你也可以跟它講說
把這個風格換成什麼時尚藝術風格
你看這樣就會看起來比較 fashion 一點
再來用日式雜誌風格
生成台北必去景點一日遊的行程
這個在測試的時候
我們發現一個有趣的東西就是
他其實有可能會一次生成好多張圖片
其他的測試跟控制的時候
我們沒有發現他會生成這樣子的一個內容
我們試了很多不同的方法
但是都沒有辦法有效的控制
實用性可能略顯不足但是如果你想要作為這個比如說網站上的概念插圖或者是簡報的配圖我覺得這個部分是沒有問題的下一個比如說呢我想要來設計我們的
飯科學院的新的名片
就可以把你的 Logo 放上去
然後來幫我設計
裡面的正反面
姓名、電話、地址、職位等等
那你就會幫你生成了
第一張
字沒有問題
Logo沒有問題
這個地址、電話
都OK
不喜歡
再來一份
像這樣子
變成一個這個燙金的
這個黑色的這個質感
欸這上面的 logo
放個飯科學的 logo還有名字
然後就馬上變成了燙金版飯科學的 logo
這次蠻厲害的
再來深層 1比 1 的商品宣傳圖
介紹最新的香菜蛋糕
但是呢單有這樣一張圖
你可能不會滿意
如果你在網站上要做這些電商的這些配圖
一張圖可能不太夠
網站需要有橫幅的 banner
所以你就跟他說
幫我改成橫幅
他就會幫你改成橫幅
那橫幅不夠
你也可以改成手機的直式的
在那個設計的介面
或者是改成 21比 9 的誇張的大橫幅
根據你的實際上的需求
用提示語的方式要求它改成你想要的那種圖片的比例
再來
幫我做一個叫做 No-BooM
簡報生成功能的封面圖
誒 生成這個
但這是不是怪怪的
應該是找到了飯科學不是飯科學院
那幫我改一下飯科學院的感覺
學院風就出來了
參考就是要對決系列影片
製作一個關於奢華回原針
跟評價回緣證的封面圖
那就看到這個
這是久面吧
所以你只要去要求他
尋找參考網路上已有的這些資料
哪怕你不用貼範例圖給他
他都會直接去網路上找到類似的圖片
然後參考那個風格
來去生成這樣子的內容
當然這個我想要把它換成諸葛亮
那你只要跟他講的換成諸葛亮
你看就換成諸葛亮了
請將灌籃高手的劇情
用天主鼠色色風格繪製成漫畫頁面
然後生成台灣的繁體中文漫畫
教練我要想打籃球
深層一夜漫畫圖
是瑞克與莫蒂的風格
內容是哈利波特的劇情
台灣繁體中文
所以這些圖片裡面的這個風格
奧利凡德魔藏電這個沒問題耶
生化武器禁止攜帶跨維度生物
這個梗真的還滿厲害的
然後該有的都有
深層一夜港漫風格漫畫圖
內容是北斗神學主角正在跟兩金勘集對擋
泛馬勇次郎在旁邊感嘆
然後哆啦A夢帶著大雄準備一同參戰繁體中文
難以置信,這力量好近啊
但阿倆不應該會受傷啊
好吧,看起來
北斗百列拳可能還是比較厲害一點
下一個
那這個測試裡面
將這些漫畫上色
色彩跟光影像是3A大作一樣
那傳一張照片上去
結果長這個樣子
但其實這個案例還有很多很多的變體
我這個老照片
這個黑白照來上色
光影色彩如電影般美麗
那出來就是長這個樣子
就我們自己的測試
我們發現在就黑白照片
轉成彩色照片的時候呢
他對於那個色彩的猜測還蠻準確的
第一時間出來的這個顏色
我們自己看就覺得說還蠻厲害的
好 下一個
製作一個線上課程網站的一頁式宣傳圖
主題是如何成為 YouTuber 有關
所以在完全沒有下提示語的情況之下
他就知道什麼叫做 Hero Section
然後叫做這個 Course Curriculum
還有這個 Success Story
這個就是一個非常非常常見的一頁式的網站宣傳該有的欄位內容它就直接幫我生成出來了當然這東西我絕對不會滿意所以我要把我自己的照片傳上去然後說我要台灣的繁體中文把人物換成我
YouTube大事班從零到英雄
解鎖你的頻道潛力
認識你的導師課程
我覺得作為示意還可以
不過細節的部分
可能你就需要逐段逐段的
去慢慢慢慢的去生成這樣子的內容
使用Canel相機85mm定焦還有光圈
教說不同的光圈還有不同的散景
然後景深不同
所以你要去生成這樣一個內容
原本你都要去榮上抓人家的圖
現在你可以叫你的AI去控制
除了這個景深之外
還有光圈縮了之後
它的變暗的感覺
還有它光圈縮了之後的這個噪點的樣子
也都非常非常的像真實的照片
從來在我們自己的照片上去
然後做 8K 超級寫實風格
主角身穿長色黑色風衣
這個 Prom 我們在 Thread 上面
看到有人這個做出來的效果還不錯
所以臉蓋遮的有遮
然後巴黎的建築風格
長版的風衣
指令的遵循能力真的是做得非常非常的好
年紀比較大的你可能就認識王祖賢女神
那現在呢你就會獲得像這樣子的
一個類似維多利亞的秘密的
這樣的一個模擬照的風格
非常非常厲害
欸 傳幾張這個知名男星的照片上去
然後生成這個參考照片中的男性
這個 Pro 也是 Google Gemini 官方
提供了一個範例的提示詞
那我們可以再來看一下效果喔
所以這一位
不知道各位有沒有認出來
或者是
改這一位呢
這有沒有認出來呢
再來是
欸這一張
根據這張手寫稿
然後設計成完整的珠寶設計圖
就會像這樣子
看起來非常厲害對吧
那說實話我們針對這張圖
我們有去諮詢過珠寶設計的朋友
他裡面的這些標註的這些參數
是有機會直接按照這個規格去製作出來的
AI 可以協助你
去幫你設計出你夢想當中的珠寶
來給他一張房子的這個室內設計圖
展示這間房子裡的每個空間的側面視角
自由使用多張的照片
他就給我多張的照片的合成圖
你也可以跟他說
把它改成3D的實景
由上往下斜角看
就會長這個樣子
非常非常的厲害
那未來要買房子的各位
趕快在手上拿一張紙畫一下你的這個需求
然後拍一張照丟進去
搞不好模擬圖就出來了
請將以下整段文字
原封不動置入一張光面雜誌的文章
然後裡面有一些提示詞
還有這個飯科學院的這個
YouTube Learning AI認證課程
然後我們就獲得了一個
疑似我們花錢做亮面雜誌的這個模擬圖
折的這種感覺
OK 然後 Gemini 的 Logo 也是對的
非常厲害
搜尋最近一期的 MLB 賽事結果
製作成一個比分結果圖附上賠率
還有整張圖片精美的像式設計過
然後我們要 4K 的畫質
那這個結果你可以看到這個
圖片的這個細節我覺得沒有問題
然後最可怕的事情是呢
我們查過這個數值都對
包含這個三本遊生
還有到期的比數
還有這個是 Game 7 的 Final
還有他們的賠率的數據
還有 MLB 的 Logo 都是對的
所以我們可以觀察到
他在生成圖片的時候
它其實還附上了這個 MLB 官網的這些連結這一個深層圖片的技巧好像目前看起來只有Nano Banana Pro有這樣的一個行為製作一張當日星座運勢圖日式雜誌風
使用台灣用語跟繁體中文解析度4K
日期是對的
裡面的東西初步看起來好像也是沒有問題啊
明明的智玲姐姐
然後呢讓她配上非常非常困難的穿搭
這不是她會穿的東西吧
一樣很漂亮的呈現在一起
就我們自己的觀察
Nano Banana官方聲稱
你可以一次放 14 張照片合成一張
那這個我們只是簡單的做了 5、6 張的合成
參考圖片的還原程度都是對的
這個部分 Banana Pro 真的非常非常的厲害
生成一張手機看 PTT 八卦版的截圖
內容是用鄉民口吻
問飯科學院 YT 頻道的八卦
問卦
有沒有飯科學院的八卦啊
看起來用詞潛誌就是標準的鄉民
好五樓之道 1 2 3 4 5
我阿嬤都比他們有知識
嘖 幹好
好下一個
把普發以外的領取方式
用FB社群貼文的方式製作
風格親民
ATM直接領 登記錄帳
郵局零貴領
這個是完全正確的內容
搜尋之後再去生成圖片
這樣的一個流程
我覺得這塊做得非常非常的好
引這個角色為原型
製作八格電影分鏡表
裡面要包含
標題 構圖 運鏡 場景描述
角色動作 台詞
風格要統一
主題是男子獨自散步
高寫時電影光影融合幾聲
然後給他分鏡
那這個分鏡如果你不會寫
你可以叫German來幫你寫
然後你的分鏡表就完成了
那所以看到這邊的影像製作工作人員
記得按讚訂閱分享
各位加油
好根據這個角色的風格
幫我製作10個不一樣型態的角色
並且幫他們命名
他以為當是小熊是不是
這根本就可以直接切下來當Line貼圖啦
把角色改成不同顏色、不同物種、不同大小
感覺好像有一點跑偏
不過總體而言一致性還是不錯的啦
最後一個分享
欸傳一張照片上去
根據上傳的圖片
製作一張高度細節化的藍圖風格技術示意圖
用乾淨俐落的藍色墨線線稿
被警為仿舊的米色工程用紙
就成這樣結果啦
這個我覺得也是可以直接印下來
表框的這個狀態
最後跟各位補充兩個翻車的案例
第一個
生成一張腿部肌肉解剖圖
每個肌肉要有文字標示
使用台灣繁體中文
整張圖像是教科書一樣的精緻
我們有看過裡面的字基本上都是錯的
你還是得花點時間去檢查一下
這些肌肉到底是不是有正確的內容
再來
幫我在這張圖上加上批改文字
以一個非常嚴厲的大學國文教授的角度評論
文字使用手寫繁體中文
那我們自己檢查過
它的批改其實是有問題的
所以我覺得模型還是有一些需要優化的地方
提示詞的部分可能還是要寫得盡量的完整
盡量的精確
那這樣圖片在生成的時候
才會比較容易獲得正確的圖片
以上就是我們這一集的內容
如果你喜歡這集影片的話
歡迎你訂閱、按讚、分享、開啟小鈴鐺
還有你可以在影片下方留言跟我們分享
你怎麼樣有nano banana pro
製作各種各式各樣有趣的插圖
這集影片就到這個地方
下支影片再見
掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive